let's think about what the two different
versions of Caroline's repository look
like at this point here's what the local
version looked like before Caroline
interacted with github at all
then she pushed the master branch and
then since all the commits were on the
master branch everything got sent so at
that point they had exactly the same
history then Caroline edited a file
directly on github and made a commit on
the master branch updating master so
this is where we are now her local
version is out of date with the remote
github version to get the repositories
back into sync she'll need to pull her
master back into the local version this
will bring the new commit into the local
version an update master now I'll hand
you off to Caroline to see this on the
command line thanks Sarah now like you
saw the commit that I just made is shown
in the commit history on the github site
however when I run git log I can see
that that commit isn't present in my
local repository to get it I'll run git
pull like when I run git push I need to
specify the remote which I've named
origin for pull I'll also need to
specify the branch I want to pull which
is the master branch on the remote
before I ran git pull I had some commits
in my local repository which I'd pushed
to github I also had a new commit on
github adding the lesson three
reflections file when I pulled the
master branch from the origin repository
that is my repository on github it
pulled all of the commits reachable from
the master branch on github down into my
local repository in this case I have the
master branch checked out so get also
updated my local master branch label to
point to the new commit now it's not
necessary for these two names to be the
same but they usually are then I'll run
git log again and I can see that my new
commit is present in my local repository
now now go ahead and pull the changes
you just made on github into your local
repository
when you're finished which of the
following is true are there changes in
your local repository that are not
present on github are there changes on
github that are not in your local
repository or is neither true all the
changes in your local repository are
present on github and vice versa